this graph shows the number of daily
reported cases of Cobra 19 for ten
countries while some countries have been
able to flatten the curve others have
seen exponential growth even when
adjusted for population some of these
curves look very different reports have
attributed these differences to three
key factors isolating cases testing and
tracing cases so to better understand
how each measure affects the curve we
decided to compare these four countries
and their different responses why does
South Korea have a bell curve while the
US has a steep slope let's zoom in
starting with China the first country to
be hit by the virus here's China's curve
but the crisis started well before these
numbers peaked on December 31st China
reported to the World Health
Organization that it was treating dozens
of cases of pneumonia
a week later a new type of corona virus
was identified and the genome was mapped
later that month China isolated Wuhan
the city where the virus is thought to
have originated a lockdown was then
expanded to 36 million people and during
that time China was building emergency
hospitals and developing a rapid testing
kit by mid-february over 700 million
people placed under travel restrictions
or quarantine and by the end of March
China had conducted over 320,000
coronavirus tests and had attempted to
trace each of the 80,000 plus cases
after a large outbreak it was able to
flatten the curve to the point where
earlier this month China reopened Wuhan
over ten weeks after the lockdown
started and over 13 weeks after the
first cases were reported its curve is
unique though because it was the first
country to deal with the virus and the
lack of public information and measures
early on allowed the virus to spread the
eventual lockdown measures that took
were particularly drastic but in the
meantime the virus spread to other
countries one country in particular has
a curve that looks different than most
South Korea started developing koba 19
tests before its first confirmed case
the country had put procedures in place
for managing an outbreak after dealing
with MERS in 2015 and I had a testing
biology ready even before the new
coronavirus was identified by early
February South Korea's first test had
been approved and it used extensive
contact tracing to identify the travel
of each confirmed case down to details
like a person seat number or what's top
they got off the bus at the data was
anonymously posted online so people
could check they came in contact with a
confirmed case this became an important
part of its strategy not only was it
testing aggressively but it was also
contact tracing anyone who is thought to
be infected could then be tested and
isolated a month later cases peaked but
over a hundred thousand people had
already been tested by late March South
Korea had tested three times that and a
social distancing order banned large
gatherings further slowing the spread of
the virus some experts say that by
developing broad testing and contact
tracing measures before its number of
cases spiked South Korea was able to
flatten the curve the country is still
reporting new cases but compared to the
over 900 daily cases during its peak the
outbreak is much more manageable and
social distancing measures are still in
place further limiting the spread of the
virus let's look at Germany next it had
a test ready by mid-january
four days later Germany had its first
confirmed case it was able to start
manufacturing tests by early February
allowing it to test about a hundred and
twenty thousand people per week by early
March and it implemented several social
distancing measures later that month
closing schools borders and banning
gatherings of more than two people by
late March Germany was testing over
three hundred thousand people per week
as of April eighth Germany had tested
more people than any other European
country this is due in part to its early
testing and its use of contact tracing
which allow testing to identify even the
mildest cases of kovat 19 the case
numbers have been high as of April 10th
Germany had the fifth highest number of
Cova 19 cases but it has one of the
lowest fatality rates in the world
some experts think that Germany's
expansive testing has kept the fatality
rate so low
but not every country was able to start
testing early the US currently has the
highest number of confirmed kovin 19
cases in the world its first case was
confirmed on January 21st and while we
don't start to see a spike until March
that doesn't mean there weren't cases
before that they likely went undetected
due to a lack of testing according to
the Associated Press US government labs
processed only 350 - koba 19 tests and
all of February testing only ramped up
in early March when the CDC started to
allow private companies to develop their
own tests but for a while tests were
only available for people who had
travelled from China or had a fever
severe enough to be hospitalized and the
lack of contact tracing quarantine or
physical distancing measures exasperated
the spread by March 11th over 100
colleges had canceled in-person classes
but major social distancing steps didn't
take place until mid to late March
almost two months after its first case a
national emergency was declared the
White House and the CDC advised against
large gatherings and states like
California and New York issued stay at
home orders but by then the u.s. was
already seeing over 10,000 cases per day
now over 40 states have stay at home
orders in place but the US has been
criticized for not implementing
preventive measures early it was slow to
gather resources while the virus was
spreading to other countries and a
botched rollout meant that testing
didn't start to expand until mid-march
with little testing and hardly any
contact tracing the virus was able to
spread silently throughout the country
the u.s. is now testing over a hundred
thousand people per day but as of April
13th the u.s. still had fewer tests per
1000 people than South Korea an earlier
start in identifying and isolating cases
could have prevented such large outbreak
in many countries it's not just one
measure that flattens the curve it's the
combination of isolating testing and
tracing countries that have been able to
do all three swiftly have been able to
lower their number
cases but those that haven't will likely
take longer to fly on the curve